Here we have alhamdulillah and subhan
allah.
These two words are part of this
collection.
When we say alhamdulillah
it includes the meanings of subhan allah
meaning to Allah belongs every
perfection
and he is free of any imperfection.
And if we see subhan Allah mentioned on
its own in a sentence in a paragraph
then it means that Allah is free of any
imperfection
and to him belongs every perfection.
But when they're mentioned together,
subhan Allah
negates any imperfection
and alhamdulillah affirms every
perfection.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here in this
verse in the opening verse he says
alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah
meaning all perfection belongs to Allah
and he is free of any imperfection. Then
he mentions the Quran right after well
what is the Quran? The Quran
is the words of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has clearly
mentioned numerous places in the Quran
that the Quran is the actual words of
Allah verbatim.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
above his creation upon his throne
he spoke the words of the Quran
to ji
and jire
learned these words directly from him
and he then descended upon Muhammad
sallallah alaii wasallam
and recited these words to him
And he then transmitted these words to
his companions.
And this is why the Quran cannot be
recited by meaning.
This is why the wording of the Quran is
incredibly critical
because they are the literal actual
verbatim words of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala word for word, letter for letter.
verse for verse
every single word of the Quran. Gibl
heard that from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and Muhammad heard it from
Gabriel.
And so
being that the Quran is the words of
Allah,
it is of the attributes of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So when we say that alhamdulillah
all perfection belongs to Allah
that perfection is reflected where in
his book in his words
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
introduces the Quran to us as a book
that comes from the most perfect in
every conceivable way
in ways that we know and especially in
ways that we don't.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has taught us
his names. He has taught us his
attributes. He has taught us his
actions.
However, that is merely a tiny tiny tiny
amount of knowledge with respect to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us that Allah has 99 names meaning that
he has told us of in the Quran in the
sunnah
that represents a drop of an ocean with
respect to the true names of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and the attributes
of Allah. Most of the names of Allah and
his attributes, we do not know them
and we will never know them because we
were not built to be able to understand
or comprehend that much.
We were only taught of Allah's names, of
Allah's attributes, what is relevant and
conceivable to us on this earth, in this
reality with our particular level of
intelligence and brain.
But the words of Allah are endless.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he says
he says you all have not been given of
knowledge but a tiny amount.
And inkbas
narrates that when
accompanied
and they rode in the boat.
When they got onto that boat, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam says a bird
landed on the edge of the boat
and it put its beak into the water and
took a sip of the water. Can you imagine
a bird put its beak in the water? How
much is a bird going to take in its
little beak?
Upon seeing this turned to Misam and
said,
he turned to Misam.
First lesson. What was the first lesson?
They saw this bird sip from this sea.
They're on this boat. He turned to Musam
and said, "My knowledge and your
knowledge combined
with respect to the knowledge of Allah
is the amount that this bird just
sipped from this seed."
How much is that? Inconceivable.
We will continue this next week
inshallah that will suffice us for
today.
[Silence]
What is